ma grande crainte de praticien et de la
médecine et aussi du droit c'est que
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué dans la
dimension médicale madame le sénateur a
parlé tout à l'heure de la difficulté
dans certains hôpitaux à avoir des
protocoles des procédures des mélanges
et un manque de personnes de médecins
etc
je vous mets au défi dans ma pratique
quotidienne venez avec moi si vous
voulez un jour dans un tribunal faut pas
oublier que je suis l'exception qui
confirme la règle les avocats sont pas
médecin les magistrats sont pas médecins
je vous mets au défi dans certaines
affaires alors je parle pas des affaires
médiatiques qui sont évidemment
tragiquement caricatural puisque
évidemment ce pauvre Vincent Imbert
tétrapes logiques etc mais dans la vie
courante vous avez parlé du grand âge
moi je vois pas pourquoi le grand âge
qu'on a créé de toutes pièces et nous
les médecins qui avons créé le grand âge
en grande partie bien sûr il y a eu des
lois sur le travail sur la santé
l'alimentation etc mais c'est quand même
nous qui l'avons créé pourquoi
maintenant dire le grand âge maintenant
il doit partir ce qui coûte cher ou une
sert plus ou on aurait perdu la dignité
mon cher confrère on perd pas sa dignité
bon mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est dans la pratique dans ma pratique
quotidienne André kosponville mon drame
il est là c'est que je vois des
situations où je suis avec l'expérience
incapable il faut que je passe des
heures et des heures et des heures sur
un dossier pour trouver ici derrière le
départ du patient qui peut-être n'avait
demandé peut-être n'avait rien demandé
dont la famille se pose des questions la
question des familles si effectivement
il y a eu une intention
d'euthanasie ou pas c'est extrêmement
compliqué je vous mets en garde quel que
soit vos positions politiques
respectives ou croyances philosophiques
ou religieuses sur cette grande
différence